all I gotta say is RFK Junior has got
some kahones for coming out ready for
president after his whole family got
offed for saying the same he's saying
now I think he's got some balls
[Music]
so did you guys hear that Carl Carlson
Tucker is that his name it happens three
times Carlson Tucker guy was fired from
Fox News I remember he got fired but um
they're not really saying um what do you
think is the reason why wait was it
wasn't it oh yeah they didn't say why
but then they're saying like oh it's
because of racism yeah yeah so they fire
him they don't against him there's no
there's no statement about from Fox
except we thank him for his time with us
like Deuces out I thought it was over
that Dominion stuff
well that's what is being like inferred
right so so Fox gets sued by by Dominion
yeah they do a settlement for like 800
mil or some [__] like that crazy crazy
about yeah and then Fox is trying to
clean house inside
um of the or clean house inside their
ranks but then Tucker wasn't really
saying anything about Dominion it was a
couple other Fox stars who were talking
about it they got rid of one of them
named Dan bongino and but but Tucker was
saying at the time that there was no
proof about any of that stuff he
actually called out
um this lawyer who was saying like her
name's Sydney Powell and she was saying
like all this stuff about Dominion all
the stuff about voting machines being
rigged and stuff and Tucker was
basically calling her out saying hey
come prove it on my show give you the
full [__] week on my show come prove
it and and she hasn't proved anything so
he called her out saying that and that
pissed off a lot of trump people during
when um all that stuff was going down
sure yeah um so that's what people are
saying like I don't know that Tucker was
out there saying [__] Dominion they
definitely were cheating and stuff so
people are now inferning based on these
releases like Joe's talking about
they're they're trying to like and fox
is leaking stuff to try to destroy his
reputation to basically get their
viewership back because they've lost a
lot I mean isn't it interesting that
they're they're like people are like
other news outlets are all trying to
smear
um his reputation with the whole like oh
how he's treating his uh wife that's uh
pregnant and then there was like um oh
that's Stephen Crowder Oh that's Crowder
yeah yeah talk about that too though no
but there was another Spirit smear thing
that was was it the racist text yeah
well it was he was saying um there was a
text about about how that's not how
white people fight how do I pick a fight
right and then at the end of it if you
read the whole text it was like at the
very end of it it was like
he was showing concern and it wasn't
really that racist at all I actually
made him look good yeah it was
interesting I mean it you know there's a
lot of people who obviously who got
pissed about that boy a lot of people
got pissed about that anyway but it
wasn't like like Joe's saying there's
people who are like I read the text I
don't think that that's racist and
there's people who are like I think it
is so you know it's it's up to people I
guess I mean Tucker was just basically a
dude who was kind of actually
reporting the news right like kind of
the truth of things and so I probably
just didn't sit well with him he just
challenged his status quo he was
definitely challenging a lot of the war
stuff in a lot of the big Pharma stuff
what I don't understand is is it he Fox
right now why is people watching Fox
like without him Fox is just gonna die
that's that's why they like lost all
their views what if they pick up Don
Lemon you know
Don Lemon was fired on the same day no
one gave a four so that's why that's why
they got to do a Switcheroo dude they
gotta they gotta get some left it'll
take so much time to build up another
Tucker though but I don't think Don
Lemon was very likable like he was
popular but I don't know how much of a
following he had because no one said
like oh my God we're gonna miss you
Tucker was like he had fans from the
right and the left Tucker also or was it
trump it was Trump Tucker or Trump but
they called Don Lemon the dumbest man on
television it's pretty funny man such a
good roast next to like so many other
people he was the dumbness I mean
there's like reality TV stars out there
like that is a [__] Savage hit also
when Tucker uh did that one podcast you
know what I'm talking about yeah the nut
boys yeah where he's literally talking
about how he spent most of his life you
know being a part of the established
band being part of the mainstream media
narrative and then now is fully
regretting you know what I mean taking
those things apart the Iraq War plan
part and that stuff yeah so like when
was that before he got fired oh yeah
before and has he said anything
recently yeah he had a statement but it
was very just like
um he didn't specify anything about Fox
he got tiptoe around a lot of paperwork
yeah right he did post something on his
Twitter
um but it wasn't like direct about Fox
like it was very to be political yeah
did he also bring on RFK he did bring on
uh Robert F Kennedy Jr who's running for
president he brought him on um just a
week prior to getting fired right so
like basically it was probably just a
lot of momentum towards his like new
voice in being like anti-establishment
Auntie you know what I mean like all
that stuff that probably just gotten
kicked off right I get rid of him that's
the Assumption he is largely seen as the
only voice that is anti-war on TV
because there's really not anyone there
wasn't anyone out there saying being
critical of like whether it's the war in
Ukraine or or even what Trump did with
um killing solimani remember like he
bombed that Iranian General
um so and Tucker was critical of that
and a lot of the media if you remember
the time they were saying today's the
day that Trump became president
anything's already present for like a
[__] year but they're basically
trying to like massage his dick a little
bit and see when you do War stuff we
give you good press yeah you know it's
fascinating stuff but there there's also
some word that maybe
um zielinski met with um the head of fox
Rupert Murdoch and maybe said something
about how Tucker's critical of the
Ukraine war and you know I would like
him off The Heirs that's a real
interesting very interesting but I mean
House of Cards the thing is people are
so focused on this Republican Democrat
thing but
for us I take this stance of more like
there's establishment and
anti-establishment establishment meaning
people that are connected
um from old media Legacy Media all the
fox MSNBC all of them they get the
donors from the same people like it
doesn't matter if you're Republican or
Democrat the same corporations are
funding your channels whether it be
Pfizer whether it be the military
industrial complex whether and then they
found CIA Ops in the editorial room and
the you know the the top ranks as
consultants in both Fox and [__] ABC
NBC all these [__] so it's like
they have on first it's so interesting
exactly they have like John Brennan on
and they're like this is former CIA
director are going to tell us the truth
about what's going on and he's like let
me just real quick say big shout out to
CIA
my boys and Langley and they were told
uh and and then Rupert Murdoch told
um [__] Tucker that he should be more
like Bill O'Reilly a warhawks school
neocon you know meaning like um like a
bush Republican someone that is more
pro-war but if you if you think about it
like Democrats or republican no one
speaks out against the war and until
recently we're like Tulsi gabbard she's
a veteran she's speaking out against the
war and Ron Paul did and he got called a
cuckoo he was called a cuckoo bananas
Ron Paul yeah and then his son Rand Paul
I think they they take that stance so I
don't know it's an interesting time now
because I never would have thought that
we would see opposition against the
military industrial complex because the
last president that mentioned that was
Eisenhower who he said be careful for
the secret societies and uh military
industrial complex and JFK talked about
secret societies too and then he got
killed he did he got killed and RFK JR
says to this day this yeah he killed my
my uncle isn't that didn't that come out
yeah well there's there's Z classified
they do they Declassified some stuff
about it but there's really no no
confirmation right yep they talk around
black bars all over those all I gotta
say is RFK Junior has got some [__]
cojones for coming out ready for
president after his whole [__] family
got offed for saying the same [__] he's
saying now
I think he's got some balls and we're
gonna talk about him a little bit later
oh yeah I'm gonna shut up so shut the
[__] up about him right now please yeah
no more rsk you know what I used to not
like Tucker you smell like Tucker I used
to not like Tucker because of uh Chris
Tucker because uh he was like a Warhawk
because he he did he was a part of that
Media Group that was pushing the war on
Iraq like he was a part of you know all
the uh we need freedom in Iraq stuff
yeah yeah because Around the Bush
Administration that's when I was like
wait this makes no sense like I thought
we were going after Afghanistan and I
thought we were going after Osama Bin
Laden why are we pivoting to Iraq and
then people were talking about the oil
and then other people were like no it's
not for the oil it's not for the oil
because yeah uh there's terrorists there
but when I looked into it Iraq was one
of the biggest anti-terrorist peoples in
the region like they were killing off
terrorists they were keeping them at Bay
and I was just like they were not part
with Al Qaeda yeah they were killing
them like like because they're Sunni so
they were they were against like the
al-Qaeda guys yeah
um one of the craziest things too is
that one of the craziest things about
the whole thing is that General Wesley
Clark came out at the time if you
remember he ran for president 2004
against John Kerry and they they made
sure he didn't get anywhere but he came
out and said hey um right after the 9 11
attacks he said they already were moving
on they knew they wanted to go to
Afghanistan Iraq Syria and Iran and he
and he's and he said every week he picks
up the phone and they want to go to
another country and he's like we don't
have any links to any of these we don't
know that they did any of this stuff and
he said they're already moving forward
with plans to do all that stuff and so
because at the time I thought Democrats
were anti-war right so I voted for John
Kerry because I thought that if I vote
for him then we're gonna stop all this
war because Republicans they're just
bloodthirsty animals and then um you
know Bush he just loves his War right
but then I found out all these [__]
about John Kerry and how much he [__]
passed occasion he was okay with a lot
of War stuff and I was like well if he
he became president then it would have
been the same thing he was Secretary of
State under Obama and they sure liked
War a lot yeah and I had a bunch of
friends in the military at the time and
I was just like dude it just sucks
because like you're risking your lives
and we're told that we're fighting
terrorism but then you look at
everything that's really going on you're
protecting the assets of the oligarchy
and I'm like what the [__] that's why I
always be passionate about these topics
because I was Bamboozled as well after 9
11. I really believed and you come from
military family military family I
believed everything that the
intelligence agencies were saying I was
like Saddam has a [__] nuke we gotta
get them yeah they got yellow cake
uranium coming out of Niger remember
that that was a story and they actually
[__] there's this guy
um who they basically ruined his
reputation
um and they they outed his wife her name
is Valerie plain they outed his wife
um to the media as a CIA asset and
ruined her career because this guy named
named Joseph Wilson I believe he was a
former State Department guy and he told
everyone hey like this yellow cake in
Nigeria stuff is [__] like that
Saddam I don't think Saddam has weapons
of mass destruction and they outed his
wife and and this guy named Richard
Armitage who was an under um Deputy
um in the state department he leaked her
name to the media wow as a scapegoat
yeah so just to sell her out and so then
she was out and then she ended up like
there's some controversy about it but it
was it's always controversy it's never
like meat nobody hap nothing happens to
these officials nobody goes to jail
Like Richard Armitage is a free man
Julian Assange isn't so you know you
gotta love it
kind of makes me sad but it is an
interesting time though because back
then I felt hopeless now I feel like wow
we're actually talking about this [__]
openly there's media Outlets talking
about it tuck Carlson was challenging it
so I'm like whoa we're in an interesting
time because could you admit could you
have imagined like 2003 these kind of
conversations happening in media yeah
and I would have been the biggest little
[__] about it too I would have been
like we gotta be there man we got we got
to be there because if we don't fight
them there they're gonna come here dude
I thought all that [__] I believed
everything there of course
much to my shame but I I didn't do
anything about I was a [__] kid I'm
just in school talking [__] he's doing
this brother
[Music]